[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
part of the 2020 hall of fame
class nba champ kevin garnett just
released a new book
a couple months ago kg a to z an
uncensored encyclopedia of life
basketball and everything in between
and as a showtime documentary anything
is possible that'll be released
next month doing big things there kg
joining us when's the last time you
played
pickup last time i played pickup
oh my god uh probably three years ago
two years ago when i used to train guys
when i used to train guys
i was probably around the game a lot
more and um
used to jump in a couple you know 20
ones or some three on threes and some
fives on five just just
just you know just for a couple games
could you play it all
could you play it all now
yeah yeah i can play i can play for
probably about 10 to 12 minutes if i
have to win a real nba game the way the
pace is now because when you're younger
dan you're
i'm chasing every rebound and you know
i'm attempting to try to get all those
rebounds you don't
get them all when you get older you you
use
energy smarter you know like i wouldn't
i wouldn't i wouldn't i wouldn't attempt
to go for every offensive rebound i
wouldn't
i would start i would i would sprint uh
three three-point line the three-point
line to be
you know be good there's ways that you
can cut like corners
if you will when you get older to to not
exhaust yourself but yeah if i had to i
feel like i could
how were you surprised that anthony
davis played last night he was cleared
to play last night
i was i was i was shocked actually yeah
i was actually shocked that he made the
trip
i was shocked that he was standing up on
the sideline
i know i've had a growing injury before
anybody that's had a groin injury
it is the worst or one of the worst
injuries you can have that you you're
very very um
limited to what you can do and being
mobile
um the one thing you can't do you can't
laterally do anything you can't
you can't even you can't get in the
lateral stance so i was very shocked
that he was on the floor and that he
had got clear i felt the same way
because as soon as he stepped
60 seconds in i go he can't play and i
wonder
if charles barkley giving him that
nickname of street clothes
played a role in him just saying i want
to get
i want to get in the game i want to have
my uniform on i don't want to be sitting
here in street clothes
am i reading too much into that first
off
if if that was the case and you cared
about any of this then
i felt like he would have came out with
a better lather you would have known in
warm-ups if he could have been able to
go or not that's one
then two i don't think the young fella
is actually i think he hears it
yeah you know but this is all about
doing something for yourself he has to
take another level
of improving his body let's just keep
this real lebron came to
la to not just you know you know
leave out the league on a great note
with a you know a great
uh establishment like the lakers
but he wanted to play with a younger
version of someone that he can actually
like similar to what dwayne did to him
in miami you know he
he came to ads in in in in la to
continue the
the legacy to continue the championship
legacy to
continue the spirit and right now he's
not doing that he has to go to another
level with his body and his training
whatever he's been doing the last 10
years is not working he should not be
out of shape during the regular season
i don't understand that one did you talk
trash to lebron
i talked trash to where i saw an
advantage
you understand and let me let me let me
get something clear out here
dan i have never ever in my life
disrespected a man
or his family or his wife or his mom or
none of that i have never in my life now
i talked about how i'm busting your ass
out here
i'll talk some trash about how you know
i'm getting this turnaround off how you
can't stop this how
i used to love the car guys moves out
before they do it
anyway i saw advantage or anywhere i saw
weakness i would actually attack that
that's what karmalong did to us
as young boys that's what charles
barkley did the greatest the greatest
ever talk it and back it up
it comes with something too though a lot
of people don't understand talking trash
comes with something but i would never
in my life always kept it basketball
we as basketball players know to keep it
basketball we know that crossing the
line crosses the line
and now i'm never costing the line but
yeah i've talked trashing lebron and
lebron has talked trash back
chris bosh was with us two days ago he
said he stopped talking trash with you
because it took him out of his game
talking trash is a mental is a mental
game you know
getting someone to first off you have to
have the energy to be able to talk and
then you have to have your information
you know talking trash about breaking
someone down mentally
and getting them to do and multi tasks
when most people most people can't
multitask most people can't do two or
three things at once
and to be able to master that is
something something different i watched
gary payton
i watched charles barkley control games
i watched them control the refs
i watched them control momentum and when
i saw that i saw that that can be done
then the referees the game started
getting better but for the most part man
the competition
is about both a physical and mental
state and if you can't be in both of
those then
you're exposed but you know um
i respect everybody who i play every
every i was getting everybody's best
and felt like everybody that was in the
league was getting my best so i know
i've never played a guy where it was
just
an easy night you know what i'm saying
you don't get easy nights in the league
that doesn't exist in professional
sports
we're talking to kevin garnett he's got
a book out it's kga to z an uncensored
encyclopedia of life basketball and
everything in between
and showtime documentary anything is
possible released
next month what's in the book that might
surprise people because you say it's
uncensored
where did you get real
where did i get real like you know there
there's
things that you say and then there's
things like somebody's gonna go oh wow
like is there an oh wow moment
or chapter topic that you have in the
book
i don't know i just think sometimes that
i would look up and some of it
was like a movie to me dan like i would
be looking up and i'll be like this is
something
straight out of you would see this in
like theater or something right
um the connection with the with all the
celtics in no way
um uh you know how my mom
raised how she raised me and my two
sisters i wanted to say it would be wow
and the reason i think i wrote the book
was because uh to show the normalcy and
the human side of me
uh and the things that you know i was
able to uh
beat or uh be able to find solutions to
i wanted to
create solutions for people who was lost
or went through similar situations and
and was trying to relate and wanted to
be able to find
some some common solutions to the to the
problem so
you know i get a lot of dms i get a lot
of um
personal mail about people and how they
how how to survive
and during rough times and sharing
stories
um i'll be the bonus i think a lot of
people were shocked that i actually
knew who avita sabonis was and that he
was a huge play
into my development and just creatively
and imagine as an imagination to have an
imagination of being that big and
being creative and being mobile like he
was i don't think people were
i think people a lot of people were
shocked that i actually knew his history
yeah dawn stanley being uh um dawn
stanley being one of my idols growing up
even though she was a female i loved
their style hurricane anderson was my
all-time favorite guards i took the
rubber band uh idea from her it
kept me very disciplined times where you
know
like i don't know man i don't know it's
like for whoever
whoever's reading it and for whatever
reasons they're reading it
looking for whatever they're looking for
um i found i found a lot of people found
some solutions in the book which is the
biggest compliment
to me at least you come out of high
school right to the pros
what kind of offers did you get to go to
college you don't have to give me names
of schools but what what were you
offered to go to college
i won't embarrass anybody i won't put it
out there like that but
um i got offered a lot a lot of
a lot of cash my mother my
um and my family to have better
opportunities
um to meet some of the most powerful
people in the world whatever that meant
and um i think i told the story in the
book where it was a situation where i
was staring my grandmother at the time
because recruiting was getting to the
point where it was just
obese and i and my mother thought it'd
be perfect or a better idea for me to
change addresses
and uh life was running so fast at this
time but i had a certain recruiter come
see me and he offered me some cash in
front of my grandma
and she went and got a shotgun and told
me to
always set the tone with people that you
can never be bought and if you be
if you can be bought once you can be
bought always and that stuck with me
forever
what did the recruiter do when grandma
gets a shotgun
i had to tell him he had to get his bag
and get the hell up out of here or him
and his bag weren't gonna make it out of
here
and i thanked him for coming through i
told him i love this school
but this this wasn't gonna work like
this and he wanted to talk
and i think the quicker she put the
shotgun together the quicker we ended
the conversation
but yeah that that guy's still around
whenever i see him i like to wink and be
like how you doing
like man yeah so that's just between him
myself and god and my grandmother rest
in peace tomorrow milk yeah
oh my grandma milk grandma's packing
man in the south there y'all i
definitely know that ain't no games
ain't no games were you were you
concerned though with
living in chicago and you know you know
it was only one year but just what
chicago was like back then
what was the question what'd you say
what what was it like you know you go
from south carolina to chicago what was
it
like were you ever concerned about just
when you're not on a basketball court
everything oh you're concerned you're
concerned every day
um um chicago was like a download to how
to survive life
like i'm like i grew up in like a little
rough neighborhood
and you know it's hood just streets
whatever but chicago big city
la new york houston uh miami the bigger
cities
they come with a lot more uh structure
they come with they come up with a lot
more
um a lot less development in
neighborhoods it's not a lot
you know so you understand uh places
like youth centers you understand the
boys and girls club that's kind of
universal so
when i got to chicago you i had to
understand how the lay of the land works
you know chicago is full of gangs
it's full of structure you know over
here is this over there is this
um the police there is very different
they speak and deal with you very
different in the big cities
so i had to get a download of all that
every day in chicago your head on swivel
your head on swivel means you're looking
left and right and if not you're in
you're in something before you know it
and chicago taught me and i felt like
chicago built me so that i was able to
go to the league
both physical and mentally you know i
was playing against guys that's in the
street
it's probably better than some guys
that's in the nba and came up
short or had kids or you know got
addicted to drugs
and and vices and just didn't make it
and um i would encounter a lot of those
didn't make it and i
i encountered a bunch of different
talent in chicago that i felt like
man not just living here is hard but man
these guys can actually play the game
and it definitely sharpened me and it
definitely got me ready for the league
and i felt prepared
i felt like it couldn't be nothing worse
than living or going through what i have
to go through every day on these streets
in the go you know straight up and down
like trying to survive
in the big city is a real thing what was
the best part of your experience working
with adam sandler on the movie uncut
gems
seeing adam's mj-ness his goldness
you know it's times where i couldn't
tell
i i couldn't it was at times where
howard
was adam and i didn't really underst i
really didn't understand like
embracing the character and he would be
in this character he would stay there
and he would stay there he would be
howard and
he would be talking to us and dealing
with us as if he was howard and i had
never experienced nothing like that i
had never experienced someone be
great in their in their craft and in
this crap and acting
and it would it would be times where um
in this dialogue we had a dialogue in
his office going back and forth
and he he was he was just playing with
the dialogue
he was throwing it and i was catching it
but i was like holy snap this is this
this is
this is greatness i'm in it i'm in it i
am in the dialogue of greatness right
here
and i understand this connection like i
totally got acting
at that point but the the dope part of
seeing someone in that greatness and
seeing how
that you can learn and soak up so much
stuff it was it was
one of the best and greatest experience
i've ever had
in life like to see to to try to do
something that you you know
you know you're not as good in and then
learn from it and then i felt like i
grew from that
being around adam every day makes you
better if that makes sense
yeah he's been a great experience yeah
i've been around him a long time
been in i think now 20 of his movies so
uh
i i i know i know i know i know what
you're talking about
uh let me leave you with this kg because
i i still am baffled with what your
celtics are doing
so you you have a great coach who goes
into the front office who now has to
hire a coach
i gotta i how about you just hire a
really great gm
and then keep brad stevens as a coach
help me understand this so i'm gonna
take this and this is my theory in this
i have no equity nothing in the celtics
other than my heart
my without about what i've paid dues to
i'm always to see at heart this is how
this is my theory on this though
so bass stevens came in and built this
system and this
i guess this um
i don't want to say pedigree but he
built he built a structure there
that the guys have believed it i feel
like
when you do that the investment is there
you know danny has been whispering and
has been hinting at you know leaving it
he and brad have a great uh not just a
working relationship but have a great
communication
and a great transparency about them
and i think danny feels that if he was
going to step away
if it could be his son austin or if it
couldn't be
numbers who is like danny's assistant
gym
um then it probably would be brad that
they put the investment there the time
has been there spent they've
gotten these players they've gotten
these players to believe in them
in in the ideal of of the structure now
it's about
putting players and building players and
bringing players and building that
structure so
i i i'm just like you're on baffled
um i've never known uh brad to be able
to
be in charge of operations or any of
that he hasn't witnessed we haven't
witnessed none of that yet so
let's see let's find out i mean he's
part of the family
i could see him want to keep things in
family um but this is all danny ainge
and him thinking and thinking that brad
can do this
and uh it just remains to be seen i mean
it's just as baffled as you though
great to talk to you kg uh good luck
with the book good luck with the uh
showtime documentary that's released uh
next month great to talk to you again
always good to see you dan man always a
huge fan of you and the show
and i appreciate you having me man thank
you kevin that's uh kevin garnett hall
of famer we'll take it